we're a remote first business we have
got an office but we've set up in the
middle of covert rights we couldn't go
to an office so we had to learn to work
remotely the biggest problem was being
isolated and how we bring people
together so every Monday we have our
kickoff meeting every Friday we have our
wrap-up meeting you know people go away
hopefully I think motivated from those
meetings to sort of know the direction
we're heading in and that kept everyone
singing on the same hymn sheet which was
really fundamental welcome back to
another episode of the recruitment
mentors podcast I'm your host Tisha
mizzouz and on this week's episode I was
joined by Jamie weeks who after building
a successful recruitment career as a
contract recruiter went on the
entrepreneurial Journey with his
co-founder Ryan who both started a
company called in tasso they specialize
in the cyber security space and over the
last three or so years they've been
building this successful company that
served the cyber security space across
Emir and us we dive into so much in this
episode but particularly we really Dive
In into what works today when it comes
to client acquisition that is one of
Jamie's strongest skill sets and we
really dig deep into what it takes to be
successful at business development in
today's market and as well as that we
talk about Jamie's Journey on building a
recruitment business building a higher
performing team and so much more enjoy
the episode Jamie welcome to the podcast
thanks for having me thanks for uh
coming over where did you travel from uh
thatcham just outside of Redding yeah
Elizabeth line now yeah I only work with
clients on the Elizabeth I remember you
said yeah it's uh that's actually a game
changer to be fair enough it is I mean
it used to take me about an hour and 45
door-to-door um really into the city now
it's
about an hour since they've electrified
the lines for the Elizabeth flying in
and most of my clients fortunately
around Liverpool streets no nice it
works I appreciate you uh making the
trip
look I think I'm really excited today to
sit down with you to really talk about
this entrepreneurial Journey that you've
been on for over the last three and a
bit years within tasso So today we're
going to really talk about that Focus uh
on that
what I like to do just give everyone
um just a bit of context about you your
journey the journey that you're on so if
I'm missing anything here let me know
yeah you think's important but just from
preparing for this I think you said in
your previous job you were one of the
biggest performers in using contract
recruitment yep right I think you said
you got your book to like 40K 50k uh not
quite 50. it was about yeah it's about
40K appreciate that stuff yeah I wish it
was 50.
um and what what world was that and what
sector was that in uh interim Finance
Recruitment and so anything qualified
okay cool and then November 2019 and
tasso started trading yep you joined in
2020 yeah um you're the co-founder of
that business with a guy called Ryan yep
then in the first year I think you hired
your first person within six months but
uh ended the first proper year uh around
400 grand net fee income and around six
people then end of 2021 uh it was more
950 Grand that for income four people
and then end of 2022
um you got to nearly 2 million in
Revenue
um and there's around 18 people in the
business you've got people in the UK and
Carolina yeah that's right and then
obviously your world is you specialize
in go to market teams is that
particularly in cyber security have I
got that wrong so only in cyber security
yeah right and then you've got other
part of the business that's more like
Tech
that's right so they do in terms of how
we carved out we've got our technical
team who plays
um sort of blue team so Defenders
attackers all the way through to
technical see so into the end users so
like your British gases your Thames
Waters
um and then my area the business focuses
on GTM teams for cyber security vendors
so the guys that make the products so
like McAfee is a popular one you might
have heard of before
um
uh it's uh there's a Netflix documentary
about the uh all right yeah so I haven't
watched it sorry yeah
um yeah so we we basically build the
sales teams for those those vendors so
our Niche is we're sort of an inch wide
but a mile deep and cover the entire
cyber security ecosystem okay cool so
loads to go into here I guess always
like to just start the million pound
question we'd just love to hear your
take on what you believe the the sort of
common characteristics and traits are of
successful Recruiters in today's market
let's start there
yeah so I would say discipline is a big
one
um I think it's quite easy for people to
be motivated when they start a job and
then
that that process tends to dwindle out
when they don't get results so as long
as you're disciplined with your process
and
know the outcome will come eventually as
long as you follow those steps and
um and then probably tenacity you need
to be tenacious you need to want it this
is an easy job to
be busy but achieve nothing so as long
as you're
being tenacious at trying to achieve
the objectives you set in line with the
sort of discipline trait you're going to
be successful it'll be really hard to
not be successful doing that yeah no for
sure I think um
definitely I really like the discipline
piece that is
definitely overlooked yeah
yeah I don't know I mean you interview a
lot of people is it quite a popular one
well in terms of what people say yeah
probably not the people haven't said the
word discipline but maybe like they hold
themselves accountable they do what's
needed
um so I think I do really like that word
uh discipline because I think if you
have
I think I heard on a podcast recently
like discipline is motivation for
breakfast and it's just like you need to
be able to do the things that are
required even when you don't want to do
them yeah and I agree I can't just sit
there going oh I'm just waiting for this
motivation to
come through in and I'll do this BD call
go get a large cup of coffee
so let's talk about the this journey
then that you've been on um I guess why
don't we just start would you mind you
gave us some really good context of the
business but why don't we would you mind
just sharing like sort of your role
within the business like in terms of how
that's ended up looking what you mainly
have focused on in the last sort of
for in a bit years and then I think
that'll give people some good context as
well yeah so we
um
yeah no real idea of what was going to
happen if I'm honest so Ryan
um you know he's the main founder of the
business
um
we saw we worked together for several
years before
um I was getting a little bit bored a
place in finance professionals my market
was you know it was anything south of
High Wickham and anything north of the
M3
um so it was quite a small area I was in
and I'd done that for five years
um and Ryan was talking about the
concept of of in tasso didn't want to
get involved with him
um and that's why it was it was too good
to stand down really
um I always wanted to do something like
it but
probably didn't feel ready to go and be
a sole founder and I don't think Ryan
wanted someone with him to sort of go on
that Journey we didn't know how
successful it was going to be we just
knew we were going to sort of initially
set up
um try and build revenue which we were
both good at
um and sort of see where it took us and
then then put a plan in place before we
start hiring people because that was
probably the scariest bit right when you
get people to leave their jobs and get
on board with you so that that was yeah
that was an interesting time but in
terms of when when we got going Ryan got
going initially I then couldn't join
because I needed to stick around at my
last company to use my private
healthcare for believe it or not I've
had three nose jobs
uh so yeah I had that one booked in for
January and then I was going on my
honeymoon in February time and then got
back
Ryan had been going for a couple of
months and he was all right we're good
to go and then that little bug come
around called covid and I was like I
might I might sit tight and just see
what happens obviously no one had no I
had no idea how how big it was it was
going to go and completely change the
world
um and then yeah it sort of bit the
bullet really to to get on board and go
with him in March and then a week later
it was sort of locked down could leave
the house at all
um and we had to get creative and the
beauty of what what we do all of my my
vendors want to sell to all of Ryan's
market and the end user technical space
so we accidentally become sort of an
event business for the first three
months when no one was recruiting
um so for us it added a lot of value in
that we could do thought leadership
events for the csos and bring a lot of
value to them
and we could have what I see so just
quickly it's for people like just yeah
it could be what so director's Chief
yeah Chiefs information security officer
so yeah they they run all the security
stuff in an end user and all of my
vendors wanted to sell to them right um
obviously not a lot of people were
spending money so we were like why don't
we just do thought leadership sessions
you know Ryan was telling me what was a
Hot Topic in the in the technical
community and then I would identify a
vendor that we were targeting or worked
with see if they want to get involved
and do the thought leadership session
with us because their their product
aligned to that particular problem
um and we didn't really know how much to
charge if I'm honest it was quite as
said I've done we've done recruitment
for five ten years between us and um
we've done events but we'd pay for those
events and those sort of leadership
sessions we didn't know a company would
actually pay us to do an event for them
um and then sort of the prices just went
up event after event until the point
where we had people reaching out saying
can we do an event with you and it was
I'll be honest recruitment's picked up
now we're not really an event company so
we like to do them every three to six
months just to bring the community
together but we did them more frequently
over lockdown because yeah no one was
hiring
um and then from that point
um we're about three months in Ryan
wanted to keep it a bit of a lifestyle
business which is why he sort of come to
me and he'd be a bit of a cash cow
um
I obviously joined as a minority
shareholder and for me it was all about
going on a journey and you know creating
value for a business and then we quite
quickly decided right we are going to
scale this and you know it's going to be
big and it's purely going to be folks on
subsecurity we know we we really Define
our value proposition quite early on
um and we work well with each other
which was the main thing so we had a lot
of fun in that first year was
the funnest year
um there was a lot of flexibility to you
know take clients out go play a lot of
golf overheads were very low we didn't
have a lot of people in the business we
had like this this two-man office
initially where we sort of both had our
little Corners to get things going and
then Joe head joined quite early on into
the journey I think we're about sort of
three three months and then we sort of
squeezed an extra desk on the end
without without telling the uh the
office company that there's actually
three of us up there
um and then yeah it sort of took off
from there really so obviously you
didn't do cyber security before no so
that's what like you're talking about it
like yeah you're talking about like yeah
just getting into with these new
relationships new networks but you
hadn't done that before no so it was
yeah that was the scariest thing for me
so that's why
you know I knew I was could do
recruitment I could run a process I
loved recruitment I was passionate about
it which is why I thought you know I
wanna I wanna really grow something and
be part of the business
um
and then when I sort of joined Ryan I
sort of had to because Ryan had never
done the GTM stuff either so it was I've
recruited for some of these vendors but
you'll sort of have to figure out so
being honest I was fully expecting to be
looking for a new job after three to six
months
um but yeah again going down to being
disciplined so how just talk us through
that like how did you because I think a
lot of people can learn from this so how
did Jamie approach I've never recruited
in this space before yeah I've never
done go to market teams like you said
you was in a very specific patch talking
to very specific people for five years
yeah you're now speaking you're using
all this language and lingo that
obviously is now second nature to you
but it wouldn't have been at the
beginning so what how did you approach
adapting to that how did you not be
overcome with like I have no
clue what I'm doing I'm gonna sound
uncredible but you know what I mean like
how did you approach adapting to a brand
new market
so it's it comes down to being an expert
in recruitment you are you're obviously
more credible when you win more work
when you become an expert in your Market
but in the early doors it was it was
working the candidate because no one was
hiring anyway so I was talking to
candidates understanding what they
actually did and what GTM was where I'd
worked with with Ryan before before we
obviously bit the bullet I was learning
about cyber security and you know he was
teaching me a lot so I understood that
the concept of it and then thereafter
you know it was sort of Ryan's wife had
just given birth two weeks after I got
on board he sort of sent me a laptop and
was like right let's let's figure out
figure it out between us
um yeah we had no system so it was on
Excel for a couple of months before we
put Bullhorn in
um and yeah the biggest thing for me was
was reaching out and speaking to
candidates you know I was honest with
them I'll be honest talk me through what
that means
and just understanding what it is they
sold
um understanding what their challenges
were
um and then providing them advice about
you know how you interview what
recruitment process looks like and just
coming across as a credible recruitment
expert rather than a credible cyber
security expert because you can learn
the market quite quickly
um but the nuts and bolts of recruitment
doesn't change in in any Market you're
in really
um you know I've adapted my style a
little bit because it's a global role
I'm in now so you know I can be up at
6am working with Israel and then up at
9pm working with San Francisco because
that's where a lot of the the product
hubs sit and then they build their sales
team regionally in each region
um so that that was the thing I found
hardest going from working anything
south of High Wycombe to the M3 Corridor
to now work in global and it's
how do you not be overwhelmed with with
everything you know you can be really
busy achieving absolutely nothing
because there's just so much to get
after the you know the world really is
your oyster
[Music]
um
does that help yeah that does yeah so
that's I just find that you are you're
sort of talking about it like it was a
bit like a breeze that's what that's why
I'm just interested you know what I mean
but yeah clearly that like you just said
then that can be really overwhelming but
what the advice that I really like there
is you lent into where you can add value
what are your skills were recruitment
yeah and you sort of own the fact that
okay I'm not an expert at cyber security
however these are some of the ways that
I can help you and I can showcase that
by
coaching on interviews or talking about
recruitment processes or talks about how
you can better stand out so you can get
in front of better hiring managers in
these things because I think I'm sure
you've seen a lot a lot of people can
get caught up on I have no clue about
cyber security I'm gonna look stupid so
I think that's really good advice so why
don't we I think what I wanted to make
sure let's just start here and then
we'll go into more of like the business
stuff but um I think I uh put down uh
here again I might have this wrong but I
think you said it might have been uh
last year
where we you uh shared with me that it
was either like 40 or 50 of the the new
logos that entasa brought on you is
involved in in the GTM side the GTM side
yeah yes all of our vendors I'd signed
about 50 of them 50. so around 60 new
logos one by the end of year two fifty
percent of them drawn by you yeah right
so let's talk about this yeah
what firstly talking about go to uh go
to market teams and things like what was
your what was your go to market strategy
how did you approach even uh our
quantities like what was the initial
strategy so
there's sort of two ways to break it
down initially it was the working
candidate understanding the market who
was hiring what sort of you know where
their interview and how we can help them
um
and just really understanding the market
I'll be honest that we didn't really we
didn't have Source breaker we didn't
have any of the AI tool to do that
market map in it was
it was quite old school what I did five
years ago when I first learned how to do
recruitment on my market speak the
candidate figure out where they're
interviewing who's hiring what what
vertical cyber security is is hot
um and then that allowed me to build out
you know a client plan we a couple of
months in decided it wasn't a good idea
running a business on Excel so
we've got a couple one
um and um then I was able to build up my
client plan
um where I sort of figured out who was
hiring and a hot area of of sort of sub
security products and I was able to
reach out to those businesses and
it was articulating our value
proposition of look we we covered a
cyber security ecosystem we do a lot of
events with cyber security vendors for
our csos as thought leaderships to bring
a lot of value to the community and they
were really interested in being a part
of that rather than just hi I'm Jamie
from montaso have you got any jobs so
that was the most important thing really
nailing down what our value proposition
was and you know it's fine if it was
just a case of have you got any jobs or
you know speccing some CVS out you can
do that and you can win work that way
but that allowed us to build more
stickier incredible relationships with
the VPS and cros and the hiring
Community who knew what was going on
across the full business
so that was one area and that just sort
of scaled organically and you pick up a
job you do a good job and it's ah you
know I see you're connected to Steve
over at this company I'll be honest I've
heard good things about them could you
team me up an intro
um and they like working with me we've
done an event with them and they want to
add a bit of value to their their mate
and you know they'll make the intro
um
what then happened was we sort of
targeted the VC space so I did a little
bit before in my last job and I always
knew no it's a longer play
um I think when you target VCS you you
think the floodgates are going to open
the second you sign an MSA or a
framework with one of them and they're
really hard to build relationships with
um
one because they're very busy they're
spinning so many different plates two
because you don't know who to Target in
those businesses because they just put
partner and they could be a partner for
for anything
um so it was identifying the VCS that
invested heavily in cyber security
and reaching out to them to see how we
can add value to their portfolios one
for our event side of things which we've
done in the past and to how a framework
can help them scale because the beauty
about the any SAS products is they get
millions of pounds in funding and part
of that is grow at all cost and to grow
at all costs you need to hire people so
it's not just one Finance director job
like I used to place it's we need 20
account execs in Emir and an account
exec the basic salary is about 100K so
the fees are really good
um and obviously
Venture Capital want to try and reduce
that cost so we can put some Frameworks
in place for their portfolio companies
and that's how we spread out across a
wider number of portfolios
which which worked really well
um and then I've sort of just been
holding on to the coattails of it all
right let's break this down okay so
firstly
love the just again just it's it's
interesting how sometimes things can
like in today's world there can be all
these different things that you could do
it could be LinkedIn recruiter Source
breaker all these things but yeah you're
like yeah just spoke to candidates ask
good questions use the information and I
was taking action right yeah that was
actually what you're just talking about
there just world-class Basics so you
spoke you've said a lot around I just
want to make sure that people will get
this so when you say value proposition
yeah what does that actually mean like
what are you actually saying what does
that look like because clearly that's
been important you've mentioned the
events we've really narrowed down the
value proposition we're saying to people
this is what our value proposition is
yeah what what like what is actually
what does it actually sound like and
what does that look like
says what what's the purpose of this
individual building a long-term
relationship with you
is the biggest thing because I think
recruitment you can either be a numbers
recruiter where we'll go to that
business because we'll get you know 10
CVS we might hire a candidate through
them
um we'll just have to kiss a few frogs
or you've got the sort of true I think
the word consultant gets thrown around a
lot um but you've got the consultant LED
recruiter where you are an industry
expert and they trust the CVS that
you'll be sending to them
um and by articulating what in tasso
does as a business yes you need your
personal branding around home Jamie this
is what I do this is my market I'm part
of in tasso and this is what tasso does
in the cyber security ecosystem
um it's quite attractive to a lot of
people to build those long-term
relationships with us because
the thing we try and instill across the
team is it's not a candidate it's not a
client you know it's a customer call
because I think that's where people
become terrified of Business Development
it's like well that's fine just call
them introduce what we do at interstate
what we do in the cyber security
ecosystem what we're trying to build and
do they want to be a part of that you
know they might be struggling to hire
people great or they might not be
enjoying it and we can try and place
them
um and that's what sort of separates
Us and other recruiters a lot of the
time does that answer the question yeah
it does no I was just thinking then it'd
be crazy to think the amount of people
amount of recruiters if you were to if
you're listening right now and we're to
ask you what's your value proposition or
what makes your company unique or like
what makes it different why should a
customer engage with you I don't know
how many people can answer that question
or might find it difficult
yeah yeah and it is I'm not saying it's
easy it's really hard to nail it but as
long as you can
as a business you know what your value
proposition is and I think where it is
hard is a in a larger recruitment
company who do everything
whereas we're like I said earlier sort
of an inch wide and a mile deep it's all
we know it's all we do
so it makes sense for those individuals
to build a relationship with us because
that's what we do and over time we've
you know we've built some really big VP
c-suite jobs and it's a very small
ecosystem cyber and the word starts to
spread and then you tend to get
introductions and it sort of snowballs
and back to what I said earlier around
your discipline it's easy for things to
slip through the net if you don't have a
process in place and track those
introductions and have a follow-up
process because you'll get introduced to
a VP and it'll be a hi Steve I've just
used Jamie tires on people I know you've
been struggling I thought you guys
should connect
and then you'll reach out thanks for the
intro and you'll never hear back that's
not because they don't want to hear from
you it's because they're really busy
and then you need to follow up follow up
follow up follow up and then if you
don't hear by the second or third time
just go back to the personal introduce
you and say
thanks for the intro I've not heard back
but um I don't know if you could try and
team me up another intro or if they're
not interested and take it from there
yeah
um yes a lot of people miss that don't
they yeah and I think it's that's where
you can get overwhelmed with tech stacks
everyone's so hung up on Automation and
what the next tool is to
try and make your job easier
but it it's it's not a hard job as long
as you do the basics right and build
relationships with people and go back to
people when you say well you don't need
to Target 200 businesses in one go you
can Target 20 businesses as long as
you've got the right relationships
um I think that's where it can become
quite a stressful job at the moment
because we've been you know I interview
a lot of recruiters for us and one of
the first question is what tech stack
have you got really and it's
okay it's not not really a question I
want to hear if I'm honest because
um yeah I mean we do we have invested in
Source breaker we do use Talent insights
and we use all of those systems now it
does make your job easier but I just
think you need to do the basics
great and you'll be successful
okay I'm gonna ask you about the VC
stuff but let's just focus on this for a
sec because I think this would be
helpful for people and I know we're
going in the grammar of the BD here but
that that is I know that's something
that you clearly enjoy have done
well at and the business wouldn't be
where it is if obviously I know you were
talking about the GTM team here but
obviously fundamental to a recruitment
business being successful is being able
to consistently win a good quality
business yeah that that that's like
fundamental to it that is a very big
part of it so this will be valuable for
a lot of people but so let's just
describe we hear we do hear this do the
basics well that we hear that chat
around a lot so could it in from your
perspective what are the world-class
Basics when it comes to exceptional BD
like what what do if I am absolutely
brilliant at BD what do my Basics look
like that I'm disciplined with that I'm
doing daily weekly what do they actually
look like from your perspective
you need to be
confident and relaxed in your process
because I think that comes across when
you're speaking to to hiring managers
and part of that a big part of that is
the system and your process of
how you know we grade relationships from
a b and c you know how you progress
someone from a c relationship to to an a
relationship and part of that is having
them in a cool cycle in a meeting cycle
and you look at the Pyramid of control
right and
sometimes interview recruiters it's I've
never met them and it's like well how
like you need to have those
relationships to sort of lean on those
individuals during you know tough
negotiation processes or relationship
breaks down with other stakeholders in
the business to sort of fight your
corner so exceptional BD for me is
having a process in place on the system
that can take the pressure out of your
brain and you remembering everything
yeah sorry if that's annoying people but
like I think that's a key bit there
just just describe what a typical
process might be it might be a process
that you've used or someone in your team
user because I think that is what a lot
of people Miss yeah and you're talking
about that stop being overwhelmed by I
have to do all this different PD where
do I start you're saying what is your
process and do you have one so could as
you're going on there sorry could you
just explain what an example process
might be yes so
um
I mean let's say you you've got a
candidate interviewing
um we call them the sort of one
percenters to help get them the job and
close the deal and it's how can you help
them part of that is a testimonial
rather than a reference so you know is
there an online manager that we can go
and get a testimonial from
um and most account execs or sales
people want to sell themselves so
they're like yeah go and speak to Joe
blogs
um reaching out to Joe blogs getting a
testimonial and if Joe blogs is already
in your relation Network great but for
this example let's say they're not
um and then sort of closing that call
with just as a high level overview
you're clearly inside but this is what
we do I'd love to have you in our
Network and I think where people go
wrong in those sort of calls is trying
to flip it to bid equals straight away
and it's about bringing that person into
your community because they've taken the
time to give you this testimonial and
one of your candidates you've got
interviewing to help get them the job
and they might be looking for a job
themselves or they might know we're
about to land series B and I'm gonna
have to go hire 30 people and I've got
no idea where I'm getting them from
and then you sort of put that person
into your database and system and then
you know whatever your agreed slas are
internally
you keep in touch with them and then
every call it sounds like really basic
stuff but every goal is what's the
outcome you know you're gonna go meet
them for a coffee you're gonna go play
golf with them how are you going to take
them from a cold contact to a
professional friend and someone that you
you know enjoys taking your calls and
calls you back so the first part then
sorry I know I made you go into that but
a lot I know that'll be useful for
people so the first part was
yeah giving your brain a break and
having processes and tools and like just
processes that you can follow yeah that
it's more of I need to do this rather
than how should like oh how could I like
you just said
you're not thinking how can I turn this
person into a professional friend you've
got like a steps that I can follow so
all I need to be disciplined with is
doing the steps yeah which is the
following up which is just doing the
high value how how happy would you be to
be in our Network okay cool and then
it's like okay right two weeks from now
I'm gonna drop them a call and you just
need to do the steps rather than have do
the thinking on the how
yeah that's it
um that's the biggest thing and that's
where the system comes into place and
that you haven't got to remember all
this stuff and if you enjoy you're in
recruitment because you enjoy talking to
people and you enjoy people and working
with people
um
you can enjoy those conversations it's
not necessarily a case of you get to I
mean I'm not perfect so there are times
I do forget to put things in the system
and you know expect everyone does that
it's
six months time you see someone just got
a new job and it's ah I didn't keep
in contact with them and then it's you
gotta make it cool do you pick up the
phone because they may not have had you
know they might you know not have
appreciated that
or they actually just didn't want you to
hound them because they've they've got a
job anyway
um and then you go on to work with them
so
um that that's the thing I found that
helped me the most it's quite granular
BD what we're talking about now but that
that's the sort of basic fundamentals of
of any good recruitment BD plan um and
just treating that human as a customer
rather than having them coded up as a
candidate or a client yeah but obviously
when you do
work with them as a client you need them
in a particular business of course and
then yeah hey everyone a real quick one
from me this podcast would not be
possible without our amazing podcast
Partners Vin cherry and Source breaker
because you listen to this podcast
you're able to get your hands on
exclusive savings on both of these
award-winning products if you're all a
growing recruitment business you have to
check out vincere who are an all-in-one
operating system for your growing
recruitment business with Source breaker
if you want to make sure that all of
your recruiters have the best tools on
the market to stand out and beat their
competition then you have to check out
sourcebreaker use the link in the show
notes in the comments below and you'll
be able to get yourself exclusive
savings on these amazing products so
let's segue into the vcps because we've
spoken about this a few times with
different Founders on the podcast
it's definitely been more in
conversations in certain industries so
firstly how long did it take for you to
get onto the outcome the end outcome
which was to get on the framework how
long did it take
probably
well the first one was actually an
accident not an accident I was targeting
one what you find is there's so much
risk involved in these deals whereas
tens of millions to hundreds of millions
of dollars that these VCS are putting in
so they tend to Buddy up on them and go
in together to minimize that risk
um I was sort of chipping away at one
and we got invited to a a party
um in Vegas when we were at a show over
there
um and then I sort of bumped into
someone and I was like what do you do
I'm a VC partner for this firm
um and then I was like what do you do
General networking Chit Chat and it was
oh we need a we need to see safe for one
of our customers one of our portfolios
as well perfect that's all what we do
um and then sort of as I said you don't
really sort of dive into talking shop at
these sort of things the conversations
went elsewhere and it's sort of all
about the process having that follow-up
process after bumping shoulders at this
party
um and then we went on a follow-up call
and then a couple of months later we
went on to place that see so
um and yeah that was quite a tasty fee
that come off the back of it
um and then that sort of snowballed
organically
um in terms of that VC was really happy
because they've been recruiting that CSA
for a year and couldn't find anyone for
the job and introduced us to another VC
that they buddy up in with a lot of
their deals
um and then from there it just sort of
snowballed really until we've got that
full Market map and the main VCS that
work in our industry
um and then yeah we've got our framework
we can offer them and then we also
support them with with events through
our CSO Community as well which they
wouldn't add value in that yeah the
value yeah so when you sorry you don't
have to go into the absolute like
nitty-gritty but when you say framework
like what we're talking here are you
basically saying if they invest in the
company or part of their portfolio
companies need to hire x amount of
people or hire these certain people in
tassels our partner and we've agreed
that they will do it at this
uh yeah it's to an extent I suppose the
yeah without going into it too much
um what I find is a lot of
an MSA or a contract's quite a scary
word whereas a framework is these are a
partner up to you if you want to use
them right
um and a lot of the time it depends on
the VC you're working with some who
invest early stages the the businesses
they're acquiring
they've got no recruitment processes so
they need a lot more from a recruitment
partner right versus a VC that gets
involved in later stages that have
internal recruitment teams they might
not need that much help from you other
than a you know exact search
so you said there these people were busy
it's really hard like what did you
obviously clearly persistence discipline
having a process was there anything that
you found worked more effectively
besides just bumping into people yeah
yeah
um yeah bum that was pretty yeah
probably not the best example bumping
into someone I bet that was because
you're you'll speak to people you got
invited there because clearly you were
building relationships like there's a re
there's um there's a reason why you is
there do you know what I mean yeah I
know I get that so yeah no so
um that's in terms of the process to
find out who these guys are it's not a
case of targeting the VCS it's doing
your traditional Business Development
targeting your the vendors you want to
to approach and then as you start to
build relationship with them uh who's
your backers uh you know these guys are
invested in US ah who's the partner you
work with there and then trying to
figure it out that way because if they
tell you who their backer is you'll type
that VC firm in and they'll have 50
people that will have the job title
partner right and you have no idea what
partner manages what portfolio and then
the thing you said to me obviously the
idea here is you get in early
because you've got that relationship
it's like in tassel yet we're just
invest in this uh company they need like
you said 30 people yeah so there's huge
obviously potential opportunities and
it's not ones and twos it's like
projects and these things but also the
long-term players if you have a dramatic
positive impact on that business guess
what like as they if they continue to
grow raise more money there's obviously
a real lot there's a short-term amazing
opportunity but also long term but like
you said to me when we're prepared for
this people would think oh my God like
we've got this we've got this agreement
with them sorted we're going to
have X number of opportunities this year
they're going to invest in all these
different companies but you said to me
it doesn't quite work out like that the
floodgates don't open yeah so how how
did you then make sure that you
maximized the opportunity that you got
trusted with and got given by having a
grid framework with these VCS how did
you maximize it yeah so they're you know
the partners a busy person managing a
lot of different portfolios so you can't
just sign this and expect great Steve's
going to do all my business development
for me and introduce me to all of the
businesses it's taking it upon yourself
to do some targeted BD and this is sort
of cold BD you know what companies are
in their portfolios and sort of reaching
out to them targeted of hey we've not
spoken before I work with these other
companies in your portfolios
um we've actually got a framework in
place with your investors
um can we tee up a quick intro cool love
to see how we can help
um and then again that just goes into a
sales cycle
um and then you might have eventually a
partner reach out to you saying hey
we've got this company struggling to
hire someone going to tee you up an
intro that's like that's the ideal
scenario but you can't rely on that I
rely on that yeah
so I know we've gone really regretting
on a BD here because I know that would
be helpful but also like for business
owners it's essential like thinking
about strategic Business Development and
that's what we're talking about here and
we've also spoken about just how you
approached it so let's get your business
owner hat on then yeah let's just start
with what what's been most difficult so
far on you being an entrepreneur you
managing leading people you and Ryan
growing a business what's been most
difficult that maybe you've been
surprised by
um
I've been surprised I suppose the the
thing I personally found we're really
good in terms of how we work in that
Ryan's great at leading people and
telling a journey and you know bigger
picture whereas I'm really good at sort
of sales operations and when we did go
for a big system change
um we needed something that would work
globally our vision is to not have 50
people in one office it's about to have
experts in different uh regions so you
know London covers the filamia region
we've got the North Carolina guys which
covers North America and you know
eventually we'll have Singapore go live
to cover aipac
um so we moved over to Salesforce
um I expected a plug and play sort of
thing over from Bullard
um that that was really tough in that we
then had to redefine all our processes
um it was a really painful six six
months that was our fault in that
internally we just we assumed a lot that
um it was sort of out the box
um and then when it's gone live it's
yeah it's all the best products we could
have put into the business in terms of
managing our sales process because it's
a product for sales process that that
was the biggest technical challenge we
had the biggest softer sort of challenge
we had was
um sort of how we bring people on the
journey because like most startups you
you bring on board experienced people
because they're good at what they do and
you bring them on the journey and then
eventually start to bring sort of other
people into the business who you might
not know and you just assume that their
process is how you work and vice versa
and what we what we push really hard is
there's no one-size-fits-all model for
Recruitment and I think that's where
recruiters look for new jobs because
they get pissed off their boss is saying
hey this is our process like your lump
it and I get you need that to an extent
but as long as it's an overall model of
these are the outputs we expect you know
whether it takes you 10 20 calls or
you'd rather you know showcase your
candidates retailered spec CVS or you
want to have a you know an emailed BD
strategy that's fine as long as we're
sort of seeing those outputs that sort
of defining that overall business
um
sort of process was the hardest part
um because at the beginning it's you
have a lot of fun and I know it works
for me right knows what works for him
Joe knows what works for him and you
know we're all building a lot of money
and having a lot of fun overheads low
and then you sort of need that structure
as you scale to to prevent anything like
that happening um
how difficult have you found hiring
um yeah really hard the people we do get
we've we get we get really good people
um but what we've we've struggled with
was
some sort of interview framework
um you asked me a question the other day
um I've got something to you around how
do you what was the question you asked
the other day when
um about the key competencies you look
for when you hire people oh right yeah
like what the yeah what in terms of what
the non-negotiables are yeah that is it
and that made me think we don't I don't
think we actually had any
non-negotiables I think the biggest
thing for us was the softer skills
um you know someone who come from not
doing Finance but enjoyed working with
people and the recruitment process and
this was a career for me not a stop Gap
um like it is for some people when they
leave University
um that was the biggest thing for us but
now we do look at some technical skills
around what process looks like
um for individuals
um
so that's that that was a really hard
bit and in terms of how how we've
interviewed that we have had to sit down
and you know put some almost competitive
framework together around the sort of
questions we're going to ask to sort of
see what the answers are just trying to
avoid bad hiring yeah you don't you
don't want you you don't want Ryan to do
an interview that's entirely different
to the interview that you do yeah
yeah I think what we found early on was
Ryan or I or Joe would find someone and
then be like oh can you meet this person
then argument this person he's like
you're literally asking me everything
Ryan or Joe asked me last week and it's
like ah sorry uh
and then um yeah now we've got a proper
framework in place but that's the fun of
the of being like a an early start and
that was everything I was looking for
and that you're you're sort of doing
everything and then eventually as you
know you get more Revenue you can start
to bring people in to be subject matter
Experts of you know operations like Sam
um honestly if anything ever happens Sam
we'd be screwed to see so basically uh
Sam Thorpe she's our ops manager um so
when did you get a knots manager
um about 18 months ago
eight of us that's an interest in the
high at that stage
yeah well I mean we knew it wasn't going
to be a lifestyle thing and the the
Cyber Market went mental and we were
beneficiaries of that because when
covert hit
um in 20 20
there was six billion invested in sub
Security in 2022 there was 22 billion
invested in cyber security
um so yeah three times the year before
um and it was grow at all costs and when
we hired Sam we you know we had like we
were getting clients emailing us and we
need to hire 30 people so we knew the
revenue was there and it's okay let's
make hey now
yeah so just because I think this would
be really interesting like I'd recorded
a podcast yesterday where we really
focused on
a lot of I don't know if you've ended up
growing your network or speaking to
peers that are on the similar sort of
entrepreneurial Journey but obviously a
lot of the the sort of UK
um recruitment business makeup is made
up of businesses that that are under 10
heads
um like 82 of it whatever wherever
depending on where you look at the stats
and a lot of people do yo-yo from like
15 to 8 or 12 to 8 or whatever and I
think a lot of the time just from
interviewing people from speaking to
people when I do speak to businesses
that are at that sort of eight stage it
is a lot of the time just like just
chaos like there's no processes there's
no systems like you were just talking
about which you've had to implement
which has clearly had an impact on you
getting more now to nearly 20 people but
with her with you describing that person
as like I don't know what we do without
her yeah like what is it what does that
person do like what they're responsible
for why have they been so impactful
because I think that is something for
entrepreneurs to consider of there's a
lot of sat down with some someone this
week where there's 10 of them and
they're like how the do we get to
20 because we know if we keep
approaching things how we are now it
probably isn't going to work so it's
like okay well maybe we do actually need
to have someone in the business that
isn't a salesperson isn't these things
so what what did you hire that person to
do yeah again this was um something
Ryan's really good at and I suppose the
how the dynamic works with sort of me
coming in and sort of Joe as well in
that we sort of hold him accountable to
scale in the business because
um yeah we're here to actually do
something
um and then we saw yeah like what you
just said right we got to eight people
um we were doing too much and we
probably weren't doing jobs we were good
at and then we brought Sam in and
just sort of little things she does
around sort of how she runs Finance with
our finance provider and sort of she's
hired a you know an account a management
accountant recently to internally to
help us and taking the finance side of
things away and then she sort of took on
board the CRM stuff I mean I'm I'm
really good at telling what the
recruitment process is and the sort of
steps we need I can't actually do it
very well
yeah yeah I'm not I'm not a techie and
it allows us to do what we were better
at and that's being customer facing and
then that again helped us that just took
us to that next level because we had so
much more free time Sam's doing
everything she enjoys which was sales
operations and the sales teams weren't
having to do as much admin as they were
doing when they'd done a deal or for
interview processes interview
confirmations we had all that support
now
um so that was sort of fundamental
getting us from that sort of eight to
ten to 18 to 20 where we are now and now
we're sort of
figuring out what those steps are what
the next steps are what's going to turn
the dial are there any other like um
I want to call them like systems and
process and now we've used that word a
lot but are there any other like
fundamental company processes that you
that maybe sounds being involved in
implementing or whatever that you think
has enabled you know give you more
confidence that there's more there's
more people but we've yeah we've got a
process uh around uh these things that
enables everyone like you just said to
not just be in the case of like how the
do I do this how the do I do
that is there anything else like you
said Finance there you said the sales
operations so like you can help her know
what the recruitment process needs to
look like but then she's the person
executing getting that built in
Salesforce and doing it is there any
other processes or systems that you've
built internally that you think's
enabled you to get to
um just double in size so the um
sort of take the in terms of how we
structure the team sort of build build
the culture
um that that was actually a big part of
that so we every Monday we have a kick
because we're we're a remote first
business we have got an office but
people like where can we set up in the
middle of covet right so we couldn't go
to an office so we had to learn to work
remotely and the biggest problem was
being isolated and how we bring people
together so we you know every Monday we
have our kickoff meeting every Friday we
have our wrap-up meeting and locally in
our individual teams on a Wednesday we
have like a sort of job mot to see where
we are to help us forecast
um sort of being able to build the
system and the support we got from Sam
to build that system those meetings were
so much more impactful and data driven
around sort of deals with clothes what
the revenue looks like what the pipeline
looks like some pretty graphs around
where we are with targets and you know
people go away hopefully I think
motivated from those meetings to sort of
know the direction we're heading in
um and that kept everyone singing on the
same hymn sheet
um which was really fundamental yeah
that's really useful I literally spoke
to a Founder this week who was there I
think they're around like eight people
and they've just implemented like some
new CRM and stuff like that and it's
like honestly last year
had no visibility on what people were
doing yeah
no clue
yeah and a lot of people like so I under
that's a really good point it's like we
did have these sort of
um yeah weekly cadences of like the
month for kickoff midweek at the end of
the week but then
having someone like salmon there can
actually add a lot more tangibles and
Clarity around where we are yeah what we
need to be focusing on so that's a
really good point how on the culture
piece then how have how have you
approached that like how have you
how have you thought about intentionally
building the intasso culture like how
have you approached that do you think
yeah
um that that was probably the hardest
thing because you're bringing people in
that you haven't worked with before
um so you sort of need to get everyone
to keep their own unique Flair so they
they stay passionate but also they're
bought into the to the vision where
we're going on so you know part of our
why people like working here I think is
because they get a lot of trust to work
remotely and work when you want
unlimited holiday
um we've got sort of the quarterly
metrics we agree with everyone so
everyone knows what they need to deliver
that quarter
um which keeps them dialed in
individually and then it's important we
bring the team together so it's not a
sort of high performance Club everyone
comes on it so every quarter we all get
together
um sales Ops a sales team
um and it's not just a piss up because I
think everyone's sick of those it's like
we're going on a cooking class
um next month for q1 so it's quirky
little things to bring bring the team
together which is important I think the
big one is what I mentioned earlier
around communicating properly as a
business and make sure and it's quality
communication I think we're guilty of it
as well some kickoff meetings we go
really into the granular around the job
and a process and what's happening with
it but that's that one unique situation
and as long as you can keep it sort of
wider business around sort of where the
whole company is that keeps everyone
dialed in and motivated to what we're
trying to achieve
yeah I love that it's it's interesting
that that is the cool thing about having
your own business that you are literally
creating and crafting a culture like
that's that's one of your jobs it's hard
because you
you do it and then you're like oh is
that right
yeah uh and then yeah you either get
good reaction or a bad reaction and you
still roll with it now
um yeah so thinking about if you think
about
this the entire Journey so far it's
obviously it's going in an upward
trajectory right so what do you think
would be the biggest reason why
that won't continue if we were to sit
down at the end of this year she said
obviously end of 2022
1.8 million net fee income like what
what do you think could be the biggest
reason why you don't end up then
continuing to grow that and that becomes
2.5
2.8 at the end of this year yeah I think
it it you know it's certainly not going
to be 100 year on your growth sort of
where we are now
um as I said we were beneficiaries of
covid there were winners and losers off
the back of that if I look at investment
into cyber security it was 22 billion in
21 22 it dropped down to like 16 billion
that was because there was that hype and
we rode the wave
um you know it's not it is going to come
down I don't think it will go much lower
than that
um so cyber security will continue
growing we're just not going to see the
levels of investment and growth we saw
um so that means we need to work harder
to be over our customer base as opposed
to one business emailing us 30 jobs it's
going to be one business where we do two
or three Deals in like like what it was
pre-covered
um so that that might be one reason
things slow down because because of
market conditions but that ultimately is
an excuse as long as we're doing the
basics right and if the market isn't
there the market isn't there but I don't
think that'll change and then how
important do you think
you having a U.S presence will be yeah
keep going in the right direction yeah
that's going to be massive for us
um you know cyber security the market is
like 10 times what it is in the UK and
the Emir region um a lot of the
companies are actually founded in Israel
but then moved to North America
um because it's a good hub for them for
one for talent and two for investment
and Market presence
um we knew we wanted to go into the US
quite early on
the biggest thing for us is we didn't
want to do it sort of half-assed and
sort of semi try and do some deals from
the UK so we were turning a lot of work
down where our customers wanted us to
recruit for them in North America
um so when we thought about doing it it
was okay let's go hire someone in North
America
um and sort of bring them on as a
co-founder for that that business unit
so they can sort of turn the dial and
drive it and we'll effectively you know
invest in that give them all of our
client base
um and then it will add more value to
our customers
um and when we were looking for someone
we didn't really care where they were
based we just needed to find that
individual and then sort of James popped
up who runs our us office and I'll be
honest I didn't know North Carolina was
on a map I thought it was going to be
like uh Chicago San Francisco New York
and um yeah it turns out
North Carolina is a really big cyber
security Hub and that's that was exactly
what we needed and confirmed everything
that he knew the market so rather than
sending a Brit over to find their fee he
knows his market we've got our customer
base
um so for him you know year year one's
just been wrapping his arms around our
customers
trying to generate Revenue but also
trying to scale a team at the same time
so yeah I've been quite heavily involved
in in helping him do that which you know
with the young family's been been pretty
tough over the last 12 months because
the the US is predominantly going to be
the the GTM team
um and then eventually they'll
start to have a CSO and Technical team
but yeah that's more of a local market
whereas the the vendor GTM stuff that's
that's a global presence anyway just as
we come to the end here I'm sure you
picked up a lot of recruitment
businesses I speak to even now currently
fully just committed in the US or have
it uh have started to make that part of
their business plan or they already have
people trying to work on it is there
anything that you found more difficult
in the US market that you didn't
anticipate
um yes the I mean Tech from a technical
skill set Jane with jokey you know he
talks a local language he talks American
so it's really easy for him to take him
on client meetings because I think
companies in the US they're inundated
with UK companies that want to so again
ride the wave and you know launch in the
US but they do it from the UK
um so that's helped us as massively
um the the sort of biggest challenge we
had was again we assumed that all of
these customers we have we work with in
Emir would just snap us up in North
America because we've got such good
relationships with them over here and
actually that didn't happen we had
businesses we'd done the odd deal with
in a mirror really need our help in
North America and then businesses we do
a load of work within Amir not actually
users and I've been in class that you
think it would be yeah so the the first
few months I was why we're not doing any
deals here like we've done 15 deals
there last year that was the what are we
doing wrong and then eventually you
start to understand it's like look we
use you in a mirror because we we can
deliver in North America really well we
don't need help here
um we need help in Amir which is why
we've got such a good relationship with
you
um so that was probably the hardest
thing sort of finding our feet around
where we can generate Revenue quickly
um and it wasn't where we thought before
it would be has that ended up being the
core of the strategy then that we've got
a track record here with you in the
mirror we've done this for you and Emir
yeah we know that you obviously also
have a team in North America who do we
need to speak to how to connect us has
that end up being at the core of the
strategy then just really trying to yeah
that's been it
um and then obviously James knows the
market over there so he's got his
contacts anyway but he's had his
restrictions and now we're actually
going to start doing the new logo stuff
yeah now we're generating a new logo
over there
um yeah it's just the case I hiring
people so in terms of our growth I think
the biggest headcount growth Francesco
is going to be North America over the
next um six to 12 months and then do you
think you're gonna try and grow that
with more us people or yeah I mean the
opportunities there if someone in Emir
wants to go to North America that
opportunity is absolutely there
um but yeah as I said it we won't I've
seen businesses you know albeit do it
really well where they sort of train
people in the UK and then ship them over
to North America to start a new life
um whereas for us it's sort of finding
local talent that James knows and you
know we can scale that way
um and have Americans work the American
Market my role is then to eventually
just cross-pollinate really so making
sure that the stuff in America we work
within Amir and vice versa and then how
do you think you're going to approach
just curious like are you gonna still do
like many remote in the US was there an
office how are you thinking about that
yeah at the moment there's two people so
we've we've got like a hub they use it's
like a shared office eventually now
we're starting to see that momentum it
will be invest in an office
um but we want to keep the sort of
values quite cool to what we've got in
the in the in the Emir business
um in that they they can work remote if
they want and there's no pressure to
come to this office I think where it's
really hard to retain people is when you
saying you're in the office
um so three five days a week can be
quite inflexible
um so I think we've done a good job
retaining people just just having that
flexibility
well I love it I think you've been on
such an interesting journey I think like
I think obviously we've gone on to a few
different places here obviously we went
really granular on the BD strategy what
worked spoken about getting into the the
sort of VEC ecosystem talking about your
business uh the business Journey how
you've approached that I guess what
what
um what are you most excited about then
because there's a lot going on right
um
I'm most excited for the people coming
through the business at the moment I
mean we're we're at a point where we've
got last year was a real big growth year
for us in terms of hiring people Tech
stack system we've got such a good
infrastructure in place now
um you know I've been able to step away
from being really into the granular and
we've got a really good team of people
delivering and picking up those
customers
um and there's such a good opportunity
for antasso to to really kick on and
grow over the next 12 months from
headcount Revenue profitability over the
next 12 months which is our our main
ambition I say but we might sit down in
New Year's time it might not go that way
but everything's in place we just uh
yeah just gotta make hey love it Jamie
thanks for coming on the Pod yeah
appreciate you having me thank you so
much for listening to the episode I hope
you enjoyed it and got value from the
conversation if you did enjoy it please
don't forget to like share and subscribe
and we'll see you in the next episode